بيشاور على موعد مع هجوم ارهابي دامن
مهاجم الانتحاريه تمكن من تجاوز الخطوط
الامنيه والتسلل الى حي لشرطه يضم مباني
سكنيه ومقار اداريه ويفجر نفسه وسط جموع
المصلين في مسجد الحي الرئيسي مخلفا عشرات
القتل والجرح جبلهم من عناصر الشرطه فيما
وصلت فرق الانقاذ عمليات رفع الانقاذ املا
في العثور على نجين
والهلال الاحمر
حركه طالبان باكستان مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
الا ان الهجوم الذي اعتبر الاكثر دمويه من
دون عام عاد الى الاذهان مشاهد الدماء
والدمار التي شهدتها البلاد خلال العقدين
ودق ناقوس الخطر لدى كبار المسؤولين
السياسيين والعسكريين في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد وانقساما سياسيا وازمه اقتصاديه
مسجد
ونحن مستعدون للتضحيه لاجل ذلك
في وقت صعدت فيه جماعات ارهابيه وانفصاليه
هجماتها لعل من ابرزها حركه طالبان
باكستان التي اعلنت انسحابها من هدنه هشه
مع الحكومه شهره نوفمبر الماضي تزامن ذلك
مع شني اجهزه الامن عند تحملات امنيه
اسفلت عن مقتل واعتقال العشرات من
المسلحين
وترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه يرى مراقبون انه
هجوم بشاور يطرح تساؤلات عده حول نجاعه
الاجراءات الامنيه ويجدد على ان الملف
الامني يظل من ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها
الحكومات الباكستانيه المتعاقبه عبد
الرحمن العربيه بشاور